My name is Skye Hodge. I'm a producer
and working with people such as logic.
I need k Kendrick.
Pretty much everybody from
Medallia. Oh hey angel. Hi.
This is sky sky.
Sky Meet you.
So, uh, what do you do? I'm an
opera singer. Wow. Yeah. Nice.
How long have you been doing
all your life? All my life.
It's like all I've wanted to do with,
see I'm actually getting
ready to go to Singapore.
She doing the opera called
Lavo him. Wow. How Nice.
Okay.
Dope.
Have you been here before?
Yes, I work out of here a lot. The great
company. They're like a culture hub.
I usually, my mind is, my
forte of course is the studio.
Where are we going to be there? So
no life though. So many events here.
This is the studio,
so,
so I don't know anything
about this set up.
What would be the first
thing that you do with it?
This is like off the top of my head,
I will more so as like if
there's a certain song that
touches you that you would
be able to sing and then
we can like record it.
And then I can just drop it in or
should it be something original?
What do you think that should be?
Our starting point,
Austin is to get comfortable.
Okay.
Knock that out and van from there know.
Ooh. Okay. No.
Oh,
oh,
oh
okay.
Hello.
Cool.
What?
Thank you.
That was incredible.
So now that we got that right,
what I did was take your vocals,
chopped it up. I got it in here, right?
Yeah.
I can also down pitch it.
Ooh,
that's really cool.
So now,
okay,
ah,
try when have the regular but
regular.
Hey man, listen to pro gets a
cold pro coproduction oh is that,
is that how people get it?
One suggestion in the middle of doing it.
If you're like, Yo, when we just do
this and maybe flip it like this.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause I'm in a certain zone.
But you probably here because you're on
outside looking in. Okay. So you know
for me there's so much about the
person that has to be, I guess no,
you know, or discovered to even
be able to create something. Yeah.
It's crazy cause I'm like one of my
brothers just recently passed this past
October, so I'm going to stay like
you do. I deal with him all the way,
but at the same time I know for sure
Halan want me to sit here and soak all
freaking day. I think I've
cried out as much as I can cry.
So now it's more so like just utilizing
his energy to just kind of push forward
and become who I need to be in his life.
My hat is off to you
though because that's not,
that's not easy cause I mean my dad
passed away and I was 22 I mean I stopped
singing for about,
I mean not very long but probably for
about a good six to seven months and I
couldn't do anything. So I mean if
you can, yeah, I mean it's hard.
Don't get me wrong.
Do you want to,
you want us to like a song
that we're doing today?
Do you want something to be about
him? We can. I should. I don't know.
I didn't have any prerequisites of
what is going on. I'm just like,
whatever vibes happen, it happened. Like
no pain.
I hear you.
Eh?
Okay.
Deep with him still.
Hey,
what did I say?
Okay.
We're all talking about experiences
that we've had in our lives.
Sky recently lost his brother.
I've lost my dad.
I am a musician because of my dad.
Maybe that's why I sing so much.
Maybe that's why I'm so invested.
Just a being able to,
to share how we deal with those losses,
that comradery Barton advise to when
we got to create it. Just kind of it.
It clicked.
I mean, sure. You want to hear?
Yes, right. Let's do this. Ready?
Hi.
I need you close to.
Oh,
hope.
Oh.